so over the weekend joe biden announced
his communications team and everybody's
really excited about his communications
team because it's filled with the ladies
now this has always been a puzzle to me
the same party that will tell you that
there are 87 genders
and that the word woman doesn't mean
anything and that in fact caitlyn jenner
is a woman and that many women are not
women the same party
that thinks that um if you are an actual
biological woman you could probably best
be termed a
vagina owner that's pretty much like the
best we can do
because you might actually be a man
right we actually don't know
okay this party has determined it is
also extremely important
for there to be lots of women at the
highest echelons of the
incoming biden administration according
to mediaite president-elect biden
chose jensaki to be his white house pres
secretary
uh this comes in news that biden is
crafting an all-female senior
communications team it's gonna be like
that shot at the end of the avengers
where they randomly assemble all the
female superheroes
in one area and you're like why did they
do that that doesn't make any sense this
is a battlefield they're like oh i know
why they did that okay so
that's the joe biden team at this point
biden's campaign and transition teams
confirmed on sunday that jen
sackey a former white house
communications director for the obama
administration and cnn contributor
which is the same thing we'll succeed
kaylee mechanini as press secretary on
top of that
several of the most prominent women from
team biden have been tagged for their
own major white house roles deputy
campaign manager kate bettingfield will
be communications director
jean-pierre will be deputy press
secretary and simone sanders has been
exiled to chief spokeswoman for vp
kamala harris which
hardest hit simone sanders because
remember she was the one who was out
there like a lot more like jenny sackey
was just working at the cnn
and she was apparently she was
desperately lobbying to be press
secretary for buying he's like well how
about you just go work for kamal over
there just over there just like okay
just enjoy yourself over with kamala
and really like have a good time saki
then released a twitter
thread to express her gratitude for the
position and solidarity with her
colleagues
she tweeted out honor to work again for
joe biden a man i worked on behalf of
during the obama biden administration
as he helped lead economic recovery
rebuilt our relationships with partners
and injected empathy and humanity into
nearly every meeting i sat in
which by the way it sounds terrible like
you know what i don't like in meetings
when people inject empathy and humanity
just as it's just a meeting person
i don't like meetings period but if
we're like in a meeting and we're
talking business and all of a sudden you
start to
start telling me personal stories with
empathy and humanity i got maybe it's
just me
i'm not super into it anyway jen sackey
says this is a team of some of the most
talented battle tested communicators out
there who are also
all women most diverse team in history
well i mean
actually actually it's not the most
diverse team in history because they're
no men
i'm just gonna put that out there that
if you're all women that's not super
diverse that's actually just
monolithic also six moms of young kids
which by the way we were told was a bad
thing
when it was like kaylee mackinay because
she has kids right i mean that's that's
not good
we're told whenever there's a woman in a
prominent position who has kids
that's not a good thing unless they're a
democrat then we can talk about how
their mom right when it was amy coney
barrett then it was like why isn't she
at home with her children but if it's
gen zack it's like she's a young mom and
she's
out there fighting for the best okay so
here is the statement that biden put out
and the media just ate this up you ready
for this here is the quote from the new
york times annie kearney white house
correspondent from the new york times
reporting
communicating directly and truthfully to
the american people is one of the most
important duties of a president said
biden
drawing in implicit contrast with
trump's use of the briefing room to
disseminate falsehoods
and undermine the credibility of the
press
oh my god these stenographers these
stenographers
did you know the only person who has
ever lied during a white house
press meeting is a member of the trump
administration no one's ever lied before
that
before that jay carney he never lied
when he got up there and he said if you
like your doctor he can keep your doctor
he wasn't lying he was just mostly
mistaken on purpose
he was like dissembling but not lying
not lying
when they got up there and they just
lied to you about the iran deal during
the obama administration or when they
went up there and they said that
barack obama found out about everything
on the news he found out about fast and
furious on the news and the irs scandal
on the news and the failures at hhs on
the news
when they did that wasn't assembling and
when joe when barack obama's
administration
was sicking the doj on reporters that
was not an attack on journalism
joe biden has now informed the democracy
dies in darkness crowd
that he is going to be communicating in
clear and truthful fashion
and they're just eating this bleep up
there eating it up annie carney from
white house
new york times communicating directly
and truthfully wow
it's back oh the best era ever this is
gonna be so
unbelievably amazing
yeah um don't give these people your
money really
hannah trudeau is a politics reporter at
the daily beast very reportery and very
politically very objective mcface
here is what she tweeted joe biden has
already started making good on his
promise to staff his administration
in a way that looks like the country he
is building a highly diverse team
at major levels of government that's
some reporting right there
that's some reporting i mean it's
reporting from directly inside joe
biden's colon
but still it's reporting is it not i
mean come on
she didn't find the polyp but she
definitely found his talking points
directly in his colon
so excellent job hannah trudeau over at
the daily beast like really good stuff
meanwhile yamiche alcindor also super
pumped
she tweeted out about the new biden
staff announcement it's the first time
all the top aides have tasked with
speaking on behalf of administration
and shaping its message will be female
so much girl power
also girls don't exist
super exciting now i just have like a
few questions
i know it's in politics we're not
supposed to ask questions about the
people that joe biden picks
i know we're not supposed to do that
that's silly talk we're just supposed to
say how great it is
because they all have lady parts right i
mean because we can't say they're women
again it's not me i didn't set the
standard here guys i'm firmly of the
opinion the biological women
are women but democrats are not so to be
fair
i don't know how these women
self-identify also i don't know why it's
important how they self-identify
but apparently it is did you miss out on
our amazing black friday deal well
we have a cure for your fomo that's
right today only join us as a daily wire
member for 50
off with code dw50 over at dailywire.com
subscribe since last year's deal we've
added so many more features and products
to our membership program
we are so excited about it we've added
more exclusive readers past content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content on apple tv and roku
that's huge because we're adding more
content every day
like bringing the michael knowles show
to you five days a week starting friday
december 4th
and if you're an all access member you
get to join all access live it's our
exclusive daily live streams with me
or one of our other hosts we talk
directly with you about well anything
we offered this incredible deal last
year we may not be able to offer it
again next year so be sure to become a
member today
using coupon code dw50 over at
dailywire.com
subscribe